[Music]
good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight we have exclusive
reporting on how Google may be stalking
you tracking your every move even if you
think you understand how surveillance
capitalism works this will shock you
with shock dust we've got an
investigation coming up in just a minute
but first we want to start with the
biggest news development of the day
there is still no evidence the Trump
campaign colluded with Vladimir Putin
hundreds of journalists and criminal
investigators tens of millions of
taxpayer dollars more than a year of
relentless searching that has basically
shut the government down in the end
nothing but that is when we haven't
learned a great deal about how our
government actually works we have just
today another trove of FBI text messages
became public last night the Senate
released a criminal referral to the
Justice Department against Christopher
Steele he's the shadowy author of the
Trump dossier so there's an awful lot
going on here are some of those
significant developments in the last 24
hours
now you remember in the spring of 2016
President Obama was asked if the public
could have confidence that his
administration would never tamper with a
criminal investigation he responded
unequivocally quote I guarantee that
there is no political influence in any
investigation conducted by the Justice
Department or the FBI
in any case . . well that sounded
definitive and yet newly released FBI
text suggests that may be false just
five months after obama made that claim
FBI attorney lisa page texted senior
agent Peter struck with whom she was
having an affair to say this quote POTUS
wants to know everything we're doing now
keep in mind at the time that Paige
wrote that the Hillary Clinton
investigation had been closed but the
investigation of Donald Trump had begun
the FBI clearly understood that
President Obama was watching closely
that's the headline from today's batch
of texts there are many more texts on
the way remember those five months of
text messages that the FBI somehow lost
well they've somehow been found the
Department of Justice has them now
Congress is waiting to get them so you
can expect more revelations to come last
night as we said the Senate Judiciary
Committee released a redacted version of
its criminal referral against dossier
author Christopher Steele
it's a carefully written document and
it's packed with information it got far
less attention than the now-famous Devin
Nunez memo but it may tell us much more
for example the Senate memo released
last night explains how Christopher
Steele deliberately misled the FBI about
the dossier he assembled Steele told
federal investigators he had not spoken
to any media outlets about his research
in fact he spoken to many of them
including the New York Times The
Washington Post Yahoo News The New
Yorker and CNN that's not forgetfulness
if this memo is accurate Steele lied to
the FBI and that's a federal crime but
maybe more important thanks to Steele's
deception the FBI relied on a Yahoo news
report to verify the dossier when in
fact the Yahoo story was itself simply
citing the dossier Circular you'd be
pretty funny if it weren't so
incompetent yeah and here's the striking
thing even after the FBI learned that
Steele was lying to them they continued
to use his dossier to justify spying on
Carter page as the Senate moment memo
makes clear there are only two possible
explanations for this either the FBI
lied to the FISA Court by saying Steele
had not spoken to journalists before
October of 2016 that's one or two steel
lied to the FBI and is therefore a
discredited source neither one is good
both are bad and there's more the Senate
memo described Steele is a sloppy and
reckless researcher an intense partisan
with passionately left-wing views about
American politics who included
unsolicited unverified allegations in
his assessments apparently some of those
allegations came from Hillary Clinton's
own associates that seems odd since the
Clinton campaign of course was helping
to pay for the dossier in the first
place but there you go
as the memo puts at any moment of dry
understatement all of this quote raises
additional concerns about Steele's
credibility yeah that's for sure
in fact it's hard to see how any fair
person could disagree with that sentence
and yet for some reason the FBI seem to
have no concerns about Steele's
credibility his work the dossier appears
to form the basis of this entire
investigation if there's more evidence
out there that points to collision
during the 2016
in pain we haven't seen it we haven't
even heard whispers of it in a moment
like this when leeks are the coin of the
realm in Washington within the primary
way people communicate information it's
hard to imagine we haven't heard of any
other evidence so maybe there isn't any
is the steel dossier the entire thing
all they've got the steel dossier it
seems to me the reason we're having this
conversation in the first place that
does not inspire confidence
congressman Matt Gaetz is a Republican
representing the state of Florida and
Florida and he joins us tonight Congress
or thanks coming up good to be on tiger
so I want to ask you about a story that
we had last night the Daily Mail broke
that congressman chef Adam chef of
Burbank California basically the lead of
on the Russia probe in the house among
Democrats was suckered in a prank phone
call into believing that this Ukrainian
group had naked pictures of a Russian
model Trump was purportedly having an
affair with he then dispatched a
researcher or an aide on the committee
to call back the number and set up a
document drum document drop at the
Ukrainian Embassy that seems like a
significant story it's not being covered
today do you think that's a meaningful
thing to know absolutely Tucker and Adam
Schiff should step aside as the lead
Democrat on the Intelligence Committee
as a consequence of this scandal while
our FBI and Justice Department were
suffering through an Obama nation an
Obama influence with these attempts to
influence investigations yet Adam Schiff
off playing footsies with the Ukrainians
trying to get naked pictures of Donald
Trump Adam Schiff has gone from someone
with oversight responsibilities to an
actual principal in this investigation
engaging with the Ukrainians and I think
for better objectivity he ought to step
aside well I mean correct me if I'm
wrong and I'm really trying to be
open-minded because maybe Trump
collaborated with Putin I mean I i'm
waiting for the evidence but the
allegation appears to be this that
trumps associates including one of his
children spoke to a russian lawyer in an
effort to get damaging information on
the other campaign on a political rival
Hillary Clinton Adam Schiff is basically
admitted that he sought damaging
campaign and a political rival from a
foreign government why is that different
well well and even more analogous would
be Jeff Sessions Jeff Sessions was
talked into recusing himself because of
a handshake in a greeting line and here
you've got Adam Schiff actually engaging
with Ukrainians to try to dig up dirt on
the president with seemingly no interest
and whether or not the information is
true or false or doctored and so if you
use the same standard that's been
applied to Republicans to Adam Schiff he
should have no role on the Intelligence
Committee as a lead on this issue and I
think that if if you look at his
credibility with the American people
it's eroded I mean it was only a few
weeks ago Adam Schiff was saying if we
released the Devin Nunez memo there
would be a national security catastrophe
that's been proven to be false and so
time and again he's lost credibility and
I think the fact that he actively
engaged with these Ukrainian principals
the fact that he goes on Russia today
the Russian sponsored television channel
to talk about our intelligence system
certainly indicates that Adam Schiff
should step aside that's the level of
hypocrisy that would really embarrass
most people I mean if you're calling for
a president to leave office on the basis
of charges standards that you you're so
finally wouldn't you look at yourself in
the mirror and say that's to you for
critical eye I can't continue to well
and what does Nancy Pelosi think I mean
while Nancy Pelosi was calling for Devin
Nunez to be removed as the intelligence
chairman even though there was an ethics
committee investigation that cleared
Devin Nunez that dispositively found
that he did nothing wrong
here you've got Adam Schiff clearly
engaging in shady tactics and Nancy
Pelosi spent her eight hours on the
floor with a different rambling
narrative so really quick do you mean we
added a limb suggesting that the dossier
seems to be the core document that
spurred this investigation is there
other evidence things I've seen no other
evidence and the reason you know the
dossier is the core piece of evidence is
because they had to have Christopher
Steele go plant news articles to
validate the dossier so the very author
of the dossier has to go create and
manufacture other facts to validate the
dossier because it cannot validate
itself it has no mechanism to be proven
true because it's all false okay
freshman philosophy class you're exactly
right the congressman thank you Thank
You Tucker